الروس يعلنون غضبهم على
الامريكان والناتو ويضعون
للزلزال الثاني في تركيا قبل
حدوثه بيوم واحد لكن لم يلتفت
فانتم لا تتحدثون عن بقرة هذا عن
بئر ارتوازية. لنكمل وذلك لحل
ان الباحث الهولندي فرانك
هوجربتس كان قد اعلن توقعه ايضا
فهناك ما يقرب من اربعمائة
مصابة. ولكن الغريب في الامر هو
مدني في فلسطين. الشرطة التونسية
تستدعي مسؤولين للتحقيق معهم
ستة اشخاص واصابة ستمائة وثمانين
اخرين في تركيا. اما في سوريا
استنساخ ناجحة لبقرة من سلالة
هولستن عالية الانتاجية قادرة
الروسي نيكولاي باتروشيف في
اجتماع مع رئيس لجنة الشؤون
استفزاز عسكري اوكراني. فهل لدى
الاوكران طاقة لفتح جبهة جديدة?
وشين شانج وهونج كونج ثابت ولا
يتغير. ليضيف وانجي ان علاقات
الخارجية الصيني وانجي يؤكد ان
دعم روسيا للصين بشأن تايوان
التحتية الحيوية في بحر الشمال
الهولندي حسب رويترز. ومن
عادت موسكو لتضع شروطها لفض
التصعيد بعد ايقاف معاهدة نيو
وكالة تاس الروسية. فما الذي
ستقوله موسكو للسفيرة الامريكية؟
لخطة السلام الصينية بجميع
بنودها بحضور امين عام حلف
كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين اوصل
الخطة بنفسه للاوكران وفي طريقه
الشيء من الاحداث في جميع انحاء
اوكرانيا. لقد سئمنا وسئم مشتركو
التوتر بين واشنطن وموسكو. حيث
استدعت وزارة الخارجية الروسية
لوكالة الصحافة الفرنسية. هنا
ظهر تأكيد جديد على تفاقم حدة
النووية وحث موسكو على اعادة
النظر في القرار. كما قال البيت
تعليق مشاركتها في احدث معاهدة
ستورث ثنائية للحد من الاسلحة
العسكرية حول العالم ونسفت
السلام. وان روسيا تواجه خطرا
ورا.
اوكرانيا كاداة لمواجهتنا. حتى
انهم انفقوا مائة وخمسين مليار
عن ناجين عالقين تحت الانقاض.
بينما تم الاعلان عن مقتل نحو
سوريا وتركيا. الاحداث
والتطورات. الاشتباكات تعود من
قضية اعتماد الصين على استيراد
الحيوانات من الخارج بحسب صحيفة
جلوبال تايمز. فعن اي دهاء
نتحدث. احشاء الارض تتقطع. تركيا
اخر ومشاهد الرعب والهلع والفرار
من المنازل تعود الى الاراضي
يغلي والاحتجاجات اصبحت بشكل
يومي لاسقاط حكومة نتنياهو.
ورئيس حركة النهضة راشد الغنوشي
على رأسهم. الشارع الاسرائيلي
جديد وقوات عرين الاسود تذيق جيش
المرة في نابلس في احدث عصيان
المتقلب. فكيف سترد واشنطن
لينتقل اصحاب العيون الضيقة نحو
على انتاج ثمانية طنا من الحليب
سنويا. انكم تبالغون يا هؤلاء
التركية والسورية. هناك لا يزال
رجال الانقاذ يجرون عمليات البحث
اليه احد. فيال هذا الزلزال
القاسي الذي يواصل قتل ضحاياه في
حرب اخرى مهمة كاهمية الصراع مع
الولايات المتحدة؟ انها حرب
وكالة تاز. وبين هذا وذاك يجري
التحضير الاوكراني لحرب اخرى
وسوريا لم تستفيقان بعد منك.
الزلزال الاولى ليضربهما زلزال
الامريكان بين مطرقة بكين وسندان
موسكو. هنا سكرتير مجلس الامن
الصين مع روسيا متينة كصخرة
وصامدة امام الوضع الدولي
الغذاء. حيث اجرى علماء الاحياء
الصينيون ولاول مرة عملية
تهديدات بفتح جبهة جديدة ومينيسك
تتوعد بان جيشها سيرد على اي
اوكرانيا فان الدعم لكييف باق
والناتو لن يتصدى. فلنعد الى
الدول المجاورة لروسيا. والا
وكما يقولها الروس فان اسلحة
قناة شهد لتعرف ليأتي هذا
الاعلان العسكري من القوات
الناتو ومسؤول السياسة الخارجية
في الاتحاد الاوروبي. حتى ان
الاخيرة الحصول على معلومات
مخابراتية من اجل تخريب البنية
الموالية لروسيا في دونيتس. حيث
اعلنت عن حصار مدينة باخموت
فلاديمير بوتين تعليق المشاركة
بمعاهدة نيوزتورت بحسب ما اعلنت
بالكامل. مضيفة انها ستبدأ قريبا
بضرب اهداف في الجانب الغربي من
الكسيريزليكوف يعترف بان مواطني
الولايات متحدة قد سئموا بعض
استعداد الحرب الى التحضير
للسلام. حيث اعلنت كييف استلامها
اسرع وقت ممكن بانتصار اوكرانيا.
فهل سيصبح الحلم حقيقة برأيكم
اوكرانيا الى الحلف ليطلق بوتين
حربه الشعواء التي وعد بها بينما
العالم اجمع? يجيب وزير الخارجية
انهم يعملون على انهاء الحرب في
واول اهداف الروس قد يكون في
هولندا حيث قالت وكالة المخابرات
لايصال ذات الخطة لروسيا. فهل
يفلح الصينيون فيما فشل به
بايدن ليكييف كانت وزارة
الخارجية الامريكية قد اعلنت عن
المدينة. مؤكدة ان السيطرة على
باخموت ليست الا مسألة وقت بحسب
حالاته وسيعملون على اضافة اعضاء
جدد الى الحلف. فهل يغامرون بضم
الحرب الاوكرانية قليلا. هنا
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
لكن يبدو ان واشنطن لا تتوقف عند
التحذيرات الروسية. وخلال زيارة
مساعدات اضافية لاوكرانيا بقيمة
اربعمائة وستين مليون دولار.
ستورت. واهم تلك الشروط هي سحب
افراد وعتاد امريكا والناتو من
واشنطن ومواطنيها في اوكرانيا
اهداف مشروعة للقوات الروسية.
ليصرح الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
قائلا مع مضي عام على الحرب في
العسكرية الهولندية ام ايه في دي
ان روسيا تحاول في الاشهر
هناك على حدود بلاروسيا. حيث
تتجمع حشود عسكرية اوكرانية مع
ليخرج بعدها الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ان حلف الناتو في اقوى
السفيرة الامريكية لديها من
تويسي بالتزامن مع اعلان الرئيس
روسيا في ساحة المعركة وتوعد انه
سيتعامل بالشكل المناسب مع تحويل
الصين وحرب التحالف الصين لم تعد
وحيدة امام امريكا نعم فقد ****
استحياء. قال امينه العام يونس
تولتومبيرج انه يأسف لقرار روسيا
يا بوتين ليجيب بان الولايات
المتحدة لديها مئات القواعد
الطين بلة على الامريكان باعلانه
تعليق بلاده بمعاهدة الاسلحة
وجوديا وستدفع العدوان على
حدودها الى ابعد مدى ليزيد بوتين
سيحدث بعد هذا الاعلان التاريخي.
ليأتي الرد من الناتو وعلى
الروسي وصل الى اكثر من واحد
وتسعين في المائة. فلما كل هذا
اشكال التهديد العسكري من
اوكرانيا او اي شخص اخر وفقا
الابيض ان هناك نوعا من السخف في
فكرة ان روسيا تتعرض لشكل من
النووية نيو ستارت ليضع العالم
كفه على قلبه بانتظار ما الذي
العالم الصينيون يستنسخون البقر
ولا حاجة لاستيرادها من الخارج
الصراع الى مواجهة عالمية. ان
مستوى تجهيز قوات الردع النووي
الكاملة مع بكين وبعد استنساخهم
لجميع انواع الالات والاسلحة في
دولار على المساعدة العسكرية
لكييف منذ ما قبل الحرب وانفقوا
الاسلحة النووية مع امريكا
العالم يحبس انفاسه. والناتو
لياخذ بوتين الميكروفون ويطلق
اعيرته السياسية صوب الصدور
واشتباكات طاحنة على الارض
والمعارك تنطلق على المنابر
والعالم الهولندي يتنبأ بامور
مفزعة والمقاومة الفلسطينية تعود
مرحبا بالحرب العالمية. هكذا
قالت روسيا بعد تعليقها معاهدة
على الجانب الانساني ستين مليار
دولار. بوتين اكد استحالة هزيمة
بعد اليوم. الزلازل لا تتوقف في
الاراضي التركية والسورية
لمعاركها ضد الاحتلال. قرار
بوتين التاريخي. ضربات من الجو
اتهامات جسيمة لروسيا فكيف سيرد
الروس? الصين تضع خطة السلام على
الامريكية ليكون اول تصريحاته هم
من بدأوا الحرب مستخدمين
روسيا عن هذا القرار التاريخي?
حشود عسكرية اوكرانية على حدود
الطاولتين الروسية والاوكرانية
ولاجل الصين اعلنت موسكو تحالفها
بلاروسيا واعتراف خطير من وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني وهولندا
شروطهم. فهل يتم الاستجابة لتلك
يطالب روسيا باعادة النظر بعد ان
احس بخطورة الموقف. فهل تتراجع